[Musique]
le progrès disait prévert trop beau pour
être vrai voilà sans doute le genre de
pensée qui a pu traverser l'esprit
certains à la noce du premier accident
responsable de la google car la google
car vous savez c'est cette voiture
autonome soit un robot sur quatre roues
dont les constructeurs nous rappelle
avec une certaine insistance que à la
différence d'un automobiliste humain un
robot ça ne se met jamais en colère çà
ne voit pas ça ne quitte jamais la route
des yeux pour expliquer aux enfants
qu'on ne joue pas à coucou peu avec papa
c'est très dangereux et que ça n'envoie
pas de textos à leurs proches pour leur
dire je peux pas te répondre
je suis en train de conduire et pourtant
d'autres accidents ont eu lieu dont l'un
mortel causé par la voiture d'un autre
constructeur dont les capteurs n'avait
pas su identifier un camion blanc sur
une route en soleil je m'appelle cédric
collomb je suis juriste et je
m'intéresse depuis ces mêmes accidents à
la responsabilité du fait des robots
soit la question de savoir qui devra
répondre à des dommages causés par les
choses intelligentes
alors je dis demain parce que la
question est loin d'être tranchée ce
même dans les cas les plus simples
je vais prendre un exemple d'accidents
qui avait d'ailleurs été recensés par
lugano il avait été sans gravité alors
déjà précisons qu'en fait de voitures
autonomes il s'agit surtout de voitures
semi autonome auxquelles on n'a pas été
jusqu'à retirer le volant et les pédales
même si des prototypes de ce genre
existent déjà
ici le conducteur arriver à une
intersection et craignant que la voiture
ne freine pas suffisamment tôt une
qu'elle ne freine pas du tout il décide
d'appuyer sur la [ __ ] de frein
ceci étant l'action combinée du
conducteur à celle du véhicule qui bien
entendu avait négocié l'intersection et
bien a conduit la voiture à s'arrêter
brutalement et s l'engloutir à l'arrière
par l'automobiliste qui la suivait alors
dans ce cas là la réaction du
constructeur elle est toute trouvée
c'est la faute du conducteur
il est fautif ne pas avoir cru capable
un robot de veiller à sa propre sécurité
sauf qu'en droit c'est pas aussi simple
que ça il ya bien une règle récente qui
autorise l'introduction des machines
autonome sur nos routes mais à la
condition du guil texte que le
conducteur en est le contrôle permanent
et ce texte dont je vous parle c'est un
traité international qui ambitionne
d'harmoniser la réglementation routière
entre pas moins de 84 pays alors vous
saisissez l'écueil du soulève la raison
la réaction du constructeur
comment est-ce qu'on peut tenir le
conducteur pour fautif alors que
légalement il est censé avoir le
contrôle permanent de la voiture cet
exemple il préfigure à mon avis la
réalité de demain la réalité de demain
c'est que plus on autonome ''sera les
choses plus il sera difficile de trouver
un responsable
derrière les dommages qu'elle viendrait
à cause et ça vaut pour les voitures
autonomes ça vaut aussi pourquoi pas
pour les robots humanoïdes vous savez
ceux qui attendent patiemment de quitter
les ateliers restent aujourd'hui
largement cantonnée mais qui sont déjà
en passe de mériter leurs galons de
robots compagnons de robes auxiliaire de
vie de robot sexuel il en existe déjà
le problème c'est que pour l'instant ni
le droit français ni droit européen ne
font la différence entre ça et ça ou
encore entre ça et ça il n'y a rien pas
un critère juridique qui permette de
distinguer le robot du tout venant des
machines ceci alors même qu'on commence
tout juste à s'éveiller aux difficultés
qui surgissent
lorsqu'on prétend de thé des machines
non pas seulement de faculté à se
mouvoir par elle même comme d'autres
robots aspirateurs ou le robot tondeuse
urbain bien méchant cela mais surtout de
facultés cognitives
c'est à dire de facultés à apprendre à
analyser
à prendre des décisions vous savez c'est
l'exemple type qui nourrit les fantasmes
de ceux qui s'inquiètent de ce qu'on
délègue demain tout pouvoir de décision
à des voitures en cas d'accident
inévitable est ce que l'algorithme qui
commande les décisions du véhicule
calculera froidement les chances que
survive l'enfant passager plutôt que ses
parents assis aux places avant
à terme la voiture autonome pourrait
ainsi devenir l'agent moral des
automobilistes dans des conditions que
la technologie mais aussi le droit
devront s'efforcer de définir alors je
suis pas en train de vous dire que c'est
le droit qui fait avancer la technologie
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
sans le droit on n'y arrivera pas sans
droit la technologie ne trouvera aucune
légitimité
les athées dit légitimité elle passe
nécessairement par l'invention de
solutions nouvelles pour appréhender les
risques liés au développement de la
robotique cognitives pour l'heure aucune
des règles actuelles semblent adaptées
il y en a une bien connu qu'il veut que
le fabricant soit responsable des
dommages causés par les défauts des
produits qu'il commercialise
alors voilà une règle aussi naturel
qu'elle est simple à justifier et
pourtant là encore c'est l'autonomie
cognitive qui risque d'en faire
apparaître les limites
prenons l'exemple des robots auxiliaire
de vie nous n'existe plusieurs certains
sont doués pour transporter leurs
maîtres d'une pièce à l'autre de son
appartement
d'autres pour effectuer des tâches
ménagères pour l'instant assez simple
mais c'est pas grave
ces robots ils vont apprendre des tas de
choses dont les années à venir et au gré
de leur nouvelle version alors supposons
maintenant que l'un de ces robots cause
un dommage à son utilisateur
tout le problème lié à la règle suivant
laquelle le fabricant est responsable
des dommages causés par les défauts des
produits qu'il met en circulation
c'est que précisément il n'est
responsable que pour autant que ce
défaut existait au moment de cette mise
en circulation
or à considérer des choses évolutive qui
s'adapte qui change eh bien on devra
conclure rapidement que le dommage qui
aujourd'hui ont été causés l'a été par
une chose différente de celles qui
avaient été précédemment mises en
circulation quelques semaines ou
quelques mois plus tôt puisque le robot
il a évolué entre temps et voilà la
porte grande ouverte aux constructeurs
qui souhaiteront échapper à leurs
responsabilités
à vrai dire les juristes n'ont pas fini
s'arracher les cheveux
que se passera-t-il par exemple en cas
de revente du robot vous savez la même
manière que certains d'entre nous moi le
premier on pu tester un jour contre la
façon dont l'ancien propriétaire d'une
voiture ans malmené le boîtier de
vitesse on en viendra peut-être demain à
pester contre la façon dont l'ancien
propriétaire n'en robots en faisait un
usage est au fond de la mauvaise
éducation qui lui donnait exactement
comme on nous reprocherait de mal
éduquer nos enfants
bref on ne sera jamais vraiment sur quoi
on retombe alors faites bien attention
qui pourrait un jour sonner à votre
porte pour proposer ses services
quoi qu'il en soit permettre à un robot
de s'adapter à son usage et c'est déjà à
n'être que celui ci exerce une influence
sur son comportement
alors pourquoi ne pas se tourner plutôt
vers cet usager en convoquant le
fondement traditionnel de la
responsabilité civile c'est le critère
de garde ce critère de garde
il est aussi ancien que le code civil
1804 code civil qui énonce toujours que
le maître est responsable de son animal
parce qu'il doit le contrôle et doit
surveiller doit le garder et à la faveur
de la révolution industrielle à la fin
du 19e siècle ce critère de garder ses
énergies à toutes sortes de machines
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que c'est bien
c'est tout pouvoir tout simplement d'
usage de contrôle et de direction qu'une
personne détient sur une chose alors oui
on pourrait être tenté de raisonner par
analogie est de comparer notre robot à
un animal sauf que cette solution
elle contredit lusage est l'essence même
du robot qui est précisément de se
débrouiller tout seul en satisfaisant
au mieux les intérêts sont utilisateurs
le parallèle peut être fait avec les
drones de loisirs il ya une récente qui
date de 2016 qui fait désormais
obligation aux propriétaires de tels
drones de suivre une formation
obligatoire notamment pour se
familiariser avec les règles applicables
en matière de survol de deux jaunes
peuplée mais la raison d'être de cette
formation obligatoire c'est que
précisément il ne s'agit pas d'un robot
mais deux choses qui sont hélés piloté
par l'homme al'inverse si on reprend
l'exemple de nos robots auxiliaire de
vie
l'argument qui présidera à la
commercialisation et au succès de telles
machines tient au fait que l'usager
n'aura plus qu'à se soucier des ordres
qu'il pourra leur donner et plus du tout
de la façon dont elles s'y prennent pour
les exécuter et finalement le jeu qu'on
appelle le droit de la consommation
celle de la consommation et sa finalité
c'est de protéger les consommateurs
notamment en les informant et bien le
droit de la consommation devra peut être
composer avec un paradoxe inquiétant
puisque plus on autonome ''sera les
choses plus assez complexe mais moins on
aura besoin de les comprendre à la
différence de notre pilote de drones
qu'on cherche à responsabiliser
davantage alors vous saisissez surtout à
quel point le critère de garde est ici
inadaptée du moins c'est plus tant
l'homme qui garde la machine mais la
machine qui gardent de l'homme en
satisfaisant à des besoins qui n'est
plus capable de satisfaire lui même
voire en faisant preuve sur lui
d'autorité quand il s'agira par exemple
de lui refuser un médicament qu'il a
déjà pris dans la journée alors résumons
d'un côté la responsabilité du
constructeur qui paraît naturel mais
qu'on aura de plus en plus de mal à
justifier au fur et à mesure que les
choses s'autonomise rond et qu'elles
révéleront des défauts qu'il n'existait
pas au moment de leur mise en
circulation
et puis de l'autre la responsabilité de
l'usagé qui est tout aussi critiquable
dans la mesure où a priori ce n'est pas
à lui de comprendre ils contrôlaient une
chose qui est censé se débrouille
tout seul alors il resterait bien une
troisième voie laquelle certains ont pu
penser la responsabilité du robot
évidemment la responsabilité du robot
qui suppose concède au mythe du robot
personnes c'est-à-dire qu'on l'affublé
d'une personnalité juridique comme vous
et moi ou tient comme une entreprise une
entreprise on l'inscrit au registre du
commerce et des sociétés on lui affecte
un capital et bien c'est exactement sur
ce sur cette voie là que s'est engagée
il ya déjà plusieurs années l'état du
nevada aux états unis en répertoriant
systématiquement ses voitures autonomes
sur un fichier dédié
et puis en leur affectant un capital qui
pourrait servir d'assurance en cas de
d'accident à mon avis on n'a pas besoin
de s'embarrasser avec une telle solution
lorsqu il suffira de reporter le poids
de l'assurance sur les épaules du
constructeur ou sur celle de l'usagé
ça coûtera pratiquement plus rien
puisqu'il y aura pratiquement plus
d'accidents mais surtout cette solution
elle me paraît terriblement dangereuse
parce qu'au fond qu'est-ce que c'est la
personnalité juridique c'est l'aptitude
à être titulaires de droits l'attitude
être titulaire de prérogatives
juridiques
alors est-ce qu'on en viendra demain à
considérer que notre robot mérite d'être
protégée dans son intégrité physique
dans sa vie privée dans les oeuvres
d'art qu'il pourrait créer
personnellement je n'espère pas et en
tout cas cet avenir là me semble très
improbable
imaginez qu'en droit français on a mis
plus de deux siècles à admettre que les
animaux n'étaient pas des choses mais
des êtres vivants doux et de sensibilité
sans pour autant en faire des personnes
combien de temps faudra-t-il avant qu'on
admette que des machines soient des
êtres non vivants mérite une telle
personnalité
vous l'avez compris je suis pas du tout
favorable à ce qu'on reconnaisse des
droits au robot en revanche je suis bien
davantage à l'émergence et au
développement d'un droit des robots
endroit dervaux placée sous le signe de
la prudence voire de la défiance
vis-à-vis de ces choses dont les
capacités extraordinaires
portas a disputé à l'homme son autorité
ce droit des robots je définirais comme
l'ensemble des règles destinées à
organiser
l'introduction des machines autonome
dans la vie sociale je vous ai parlé
aujourd'hui du droit de la
responsabilité civile j'aurais pu vous
parler d'autres matières comme le droit
des incapacités
faudra-t-il que demain le juge des
tutelles se prononce sur l'opportunité
de dépêcher à rouleaux auxiliaire de vie
au chevet d'une personne dépendante
surtout si elle souffre de troubles
mentaux c'est une vocation
alors on le voit se doit des robots il
n'existe pas encore mais c'est déjà la
réalité d'aujourd'hui
en tout cas celle de demain mais pour
l'instant
ne craignez rien si un jour vous décidez
d'acquérir un robot sexuel et que
parions soirées d'hiver vous y allez un
peu fort
paroles de juristes touche que vous
risquez c'est de faire sauter la
garantie
merci
[Applaudissements]